the war crimes trial of a Navy SEAL in
San Diego took a sharp turn with a
shocking admission by a key witness Navy
SEAL Chief Edward Gallagher is charged
with the 2017 stabbing death of an Isis
prisoner yesterday another SEAL told a
court-martial
he killed the prisoner Carter Evans
looks at the surprise confession that
threatens to upset this controversial
case my husband will be exonerated in
his innocence will be known to everybody
after way too long the wife of accused
Navy SEAL Chief Edward Gallagher says
her husband has been vindicated after
another seal claimed responsibility for
a teenage Isis fighters death
prosecution witness and seal medic Corey
Scott told the court the boy was sedated
and breathing through a tube
when Gallagher stabbed him in the neck
when Scott said the injuries weren't
life threatening he then claimed he was
the one who killed the teen by holding
his thumb over his tracheal tube until
he quit breathing he said he did it to
spare him from torture by Iraqi forces
Gallagher's defense team has claimed he
only treated the prisoner for a
collapsed lung and that the murder
accusations are false the trial is
certainly going to continue but I
expected at the end of this there will
be a not guilty verdict this video shows
the teen injured in an airstrike before
his capture he told an Iraqi news crew
his father threatened to kill him if he
didn't join Isis
Scott was granted immunity from criminal
prosecution this week and prosecutors
accused him of lying to protect
Gallagher his testimony contradicted his
previous statements as well as the
testimony of other seals one said
Gallagher posed in front of the corpse
and prosecutors say he texted a photo
saying good story behind this got him
with my hunting knife the impact of
Scott's testimony will ultimately be up
to the military jury this guy who had a
front-row seat to what chief Gallagher
did says very clearly that he stabbed a
captive in the neck and then left now
the fact that the men
a few minutes later made a mercy killing
I don't know if that exonerates their
client Gallagher is also accused of
randomly shooting in Iraqi civilians and
threatening to retaliate against members
of his team who reported it for CBS this
morning Carter Evans prosecutors say
this does not change anything and they
will not drop the premeditated murder
charges they say the credibility of a
witness is for the jury to decide